hey what's up everybody meta world peace
here
check me out on a bootleg kev podcast
boulet cat podcast special guest in here
the legend meta world peace ladies and
gentlemen welcome man it's so good to
meet you man i was just telling you uh
off camera when i was 16 i i was uh went
to your video shoot that you weren't
there for but mike jones was there for
in phoenix yeah uh shout out to mike
jones man absolutely shout out to my
took a while to get that video done
there was low riders and [ __ ] we're at
my boys barbershop it was nice man it
was nice it took a little too long to
get it done but
i mean it was definitely an honor to be
on there with mike jones because he was
kind of hot at that time
um i guess his [ __ ] he was on fire at
that time he wasn't like oh he he was
just like
he was he was he was still on fire yeah
that was like still tipping it was still
it was like right at that error
it was that it was that yeah it was like
a really big deal that he was in he was
but that was like kind of his last life
that was his last leg yes that was a
long time ago yeah he had his ice age
big old ice age yeah ice age yeah shout
out to isis shout out to houston back
then when you were do because you would
you had like a lot of records with a lot
of people were like
were you were you paying for them or
were just people doing them on the
streets because they [ __ ] with you
some people would do it on the strength
some some things i paid for um in music
um that i didn't i now i understand you
don't really need to pay mm-hmm to get
into the business you need to work yeah
that's the beginning you can't buy your
way into the music career you cannot buy
your way into music business yeah no do
you feel like you tried that
well it wasn't like i was trying to but
i mean i thought i had a shot i did try
to do certain things like we had a
studio at one point in time in jersey
true warrior rock chalice foul monday um
i remember you know what's crazy the
chalice guy met you probably met him he
did a lot he engineered he produced he
was out here in l.a was he in phoenix at
all he was at phoenix he was there then
i definitely he really told me because i
couldn't make it that day so i was yeah
i met him at the shoot i remember that
name yeah jealous yeah he was on a nice
album the um the 41st side album he was
the only one with a solo it was called
money wow and nas blessed him and let
him do a solo
and that was big yo you have um one of
the more iconic just i feel like careers
in the nba when we think of like
when i think of like
personalities and just story lines that
you know
we think of guys like yourself guys like
shaq guys like dennis rodman we're just
like man just what a crazy
rollercoaster of a ride your career was
like i remember
when you got drafted by the bulls
i grew up a jordan fan obviously i
always was [ __ ] with the suns but i
mean i was born in 87 so everyone was a
bulls fan
um
and i remember that kind of being just
like the first era
of like it was like you jamal crawford i
want to say was jaylen rose on that team
um nah i got traded for jalen you got
traded for jalen that's what it was who
else was on that team because i think
there was the eddie curry tyson taylor
drafts i played with eddie tyson so the
first year i got there with me elton
brand
it was um corey benjamin was ready
benjamin yeah then like will perdue
jackie simpkins randy brown they was
there so those guys were the leftovers
from the old run they was there and then
the next year
we had like
um jamar crawford king yep marcus pfizer
mike marcus yep yep yeah elton brand was
still there
and then the year after that
the elton got traded
tyson kane eddie curry kane ron mercer
ron mercer i remember ron
ron
mercer
yo it's crazy because like if you think
back to that bulls like
period of time there was so much talent
on those teams when you really think
back and you think damn they had ellen
brand they had you they had some guys
jamal crawford
um how hard was it getting drafted to
the bulls and being a part of the team
that like was like the rebuilding
process when jordan's statues outside
and that was tough because i'm really
competitive that's one of the reasons i
got traded
because um
i didn't really care what my skill level
was but
i couldn't take losing and i knew
that jordan was somebody i always wanted
to be like so i would practice and i
really loved his defense so i was always
like trying to be like him on defense
but um
you know to in order to be successful
there
you got to set the bar jordan set the
bar so okay i'm going to try to reach
that but then
when i don't reach it
you know i didn't i wasn't able to deal
with the adversity like saying like okay
you lost and it's cool we're losing with
me not it's that it's not cool
back then it wasn't cool versus now it's
like no we're tanking there's a draft
pick involved
right yeah and that's going i didn't
really understand that part of the
business
i got i mean i probably could have dealt
with losing
if
we could have did
something about it but when you're
tanking on purpose that's a little
difficult yo they had said that there
was a port in time where you were in the
nba that you like chose to still live in
queensbridge in qb is that true
yeah that was a gift from the curse like
um
because my mom
when i when i made it i was like mom we
gonna move out
go to chicago she's like nah i'ma stay
in queensbridge so my mom stayed in
queensland for a couple years
and so i kind of redid the apartment in
queens bridge
but it was like i was trying to do
something else
but my mom just wanted to stay in hood
so i mean for the most part i just
stayed in the hood
and then um
you know uh i was looking for an
apartment back home in queensbridge i
got my you know
i was always close by
it's crazy because you think like you
make it you become a millionaire you're
supposed to kind of go the other way
right
i mean you should
you're not supposed to as things it's
it's like you're most vulnerable at home
when you when you make it because you
that's where most of your haters are
probably at that's not for me i got a
lot of love in my neighborhood
you know i'm saying so it's not like
other neighborhoods
you know um
you know our neighborhood's a little
different
but you know but i think like when you
make it like professional whatever
you're doing music sports
you have other opportunities
you know what i'm saying it's things you
could do yeah that you don't really need
to just you should be doing actually
right right right if you get if somebody
write you a rapper you get a five
million dollar check
you should be thinking differently you
should start thinking differently yeah
yeah there's opportunity for you right
so that's probably like not everyone
sees that
you know jay-z he from the hood but he
obviously had a huge plan
and when you when you start planning
that early
i mean you know sky's the limit and
that's kind of what i'm hoping more
people do what what happened for you to
kind of change your mind state
it was weird man because like i really
like queensbridge i'm very proud
queensbridge guy
you know so like for me it was all about
queensbridge you know growing up you
know nice mob deep and we want to keep
that going you you rep it you know and
it's all about us that's it yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying and then um
that was such a that was like a
big part of my life
you know what i'm saying growing up
from when i got drafted when i was in
the nba
you know and i wasn't coming into the
nba to make friends right and i did i
mean i got friends but initially
my friends was back home
i'm coming here to just you know to work
to work it's a job to do what i got to
do maybe lock somebody up and then like
go back home
you know and go back home my friends
and that's kind of i mean that was a
gift from the curse and i was really
focused on my game and focus on my like
kind of
my hood
you know i mean like that was there and
my family too like my family but
i wasn't really
nothing else really came with that
growing up obviously queensbridge is
like when we think of hip-hop we think
of it as i mean i i mean nas is my
favorite mc ever so like uh
yeah queensbridge was everything as a
kid that big qb chain qb's finest the
album like yeah everything yeah um
how how connected were you to like
kind of what was going on in the hip-hop
scene like coming up like obviously you
were a star on the basketball scene like
yeah there's no secret you were probably
gonna make it to the league right right
right um when you're that talented you
probably are granted access or
opportunity to be around
you know maybe the nazis the prodigies
or the havocs of the world were you were
you able to connect with that scene at
all coming up well i was always in the
streets anyway playing basketball you
know i'll be out to 12
2 a.m 3 a.m you know the house is
outside doing anything
you know what i mean i'm outside doing
my thing you know i mean playing
basketball and when i'm finished doing
what i do i'm going to chill with my you
know with the with the people on the
block yeah so i wasn't necessarily like
into
i wasn't like around a rap crowd but we
just family so you might see havoc
walking out of this building
you know
my family um
they did their time already and i always
ask them could i tell some stories i
always ask anybody before i tell a story
but like you know my family live on the
same
same floor as havoc wow have a door
right here i think havoc was 3a
and then i was
3b or something like that right back
here you know and my family moving
product out to crib and stuff like that
but this is right and at that time about
1993
havoc and his brother killed rp killer b
i know
kill of me when he was when he wasn't
killer b
you know what i'm saying yeah she said
93 i feel like that was even before
juvenile hell low key that's for sure
yeah
i remember killer bee when he used to
have a smile on his face
and then one day i got back home
i got back home one day i was aau
i get back home i go back on the block
everybody on the bench i go to the block
and i see killer
over there just like mean mugging
and i'm like
damn something happened to killer today
but but then when i was asking my boy
he's like nah he's for the last year you
know he's been like kind of just like on
some gangster [ __ ]
so
then i got accustomed to that killer
um
you know and it was kind of awkward and
then shortly after that he you know um
he died shortly after that
um
but you know i grew up on the mob d
block i'm from 10th street though
i'm from the block then the knives block
is like diagonal from mine then you got
like m c shannon and molly mall of
course then you got you know mega
you know on the 40 side shout out to
cormega nature
was big noid from qb no
yeah hit my mom my mom remember
screwball yeah screw up so my mom know
your mom and twin mom
shout out big twin they always best
friends
so trying to be spend night at my house
um sometimes i remember we had a lot of
mice in our house so twins come over rp
big twin so twin the tournament come
over we they kill the mice for us
we be little kids running and running
from the mice to wake wake twin up he'd
kill him nice
um no he'd be spending the night we'll
go to their house and the screwball
hostile rp hostile yeah
that's my brother-in-law he got a baby
by my uh
by my sister three babies i remember
that album that they came out with i
want to say what the [ __ ] it was like
the the cartoon yeah yeah that [ __ ] was
hard that's one of the greatest shows
that's one of the most slept on albums
but i'm not talking about like in the
history i just mean even in hip-hop
people sleep on that house incredible
yeah but but if you're not it's like me
listening to like you know somebody from
houston
underground some underground qb [ __ ]
right it's underground key it's one of
the greatest qb albums like nas
obviously has the greatest qb album
mm-hmm and i'm pretty sure he's out but
then you got mob deep so you can easily
say nas is like his top three albums one
two and three but you can also make an
argument that like i don't know i think
the infamous is probably
i would take the infamous over
everything except illmatic and
stillmatic was pretty stillmatic and it
was written
he's that's what i'm saying so you guys
so the if so the infamous is for three
or four because the infamous is
damn it's so it's some short ones
and the infamous i feel like probably
even if we're just talking about an
album based on qb
it's probably higher than stillmatic as
far as just what was being talked about
well when you got eaten
see when you
in terms of like the energy of where of
of like
queen's bridge
because the infamous had that energy
that like felt like they recorded that
[ __ ] in the projects no no for sure that
already made it stillmatic was already
yeah i would put infamous over
stillmatic we're talking about just like
queensbridge
queensbridge like it's a lot of great
albums obviously illmatic
yeah was incredible it's my favorite
album ever that's incredible album then
you got um
then maybe the infamous them for missus
but then you got but then you got
stillmatic it was written too man you
got it was wren so then but then you got
murder music
so i think like murder music was amazing
infamous is either like two or three
right it's like two it's like two or
three yeah shout out to mob you know
what i'm saying then you got screwball
then you got im three album they got one
of the great then you got um the
realness with mega i should say even
hnic shout out to the nation i see keep
it thorough is one of the best beats
ever this is what i'm saying so shout
out to alchemist shout out to alchemist
um what was it about your um your come
up was it your mom because you could
have easily like you said you were
outside playing basketball until
midnight when people were hustling
you're obviously running in those
circles you could have went the other
way easily like what was it about
just your dedication maybe your
upbringing that you were able to stick
with basketball because we always hear
people who have hoop dreams and then
they end up getting caught up in the
system yeah catching a case like how did
you
push through all that it was it was
difficult you know what i mean because
my friends you know a lot of my friends
was
we grow up 10 years old they turned 11
they doing something different next one
turned 12 he doing something different
it's like damn you know what i'm saying
and then you still tied
so then then you're getting in some
trouble
then you're like okay if i do this again
i'm probably going to go to jail are you
so i had to make those decisions to
focus on basketball and really really
lock in
you know um
and getting
a lot so many people around was going to
jail and then some people were actually
dying you know once you get in some beef
it's hard to navigate your way out true
so you're going to navigate your way out
either you're going to do a called you
and or you know somebody going to let
something fly you know and then
somebody's going to get shot and and
that's and that's what you don't want
but it's just so hard so i just i was
trying to stay cool and also like a lot
of my ball players you know a lot of my
ball players was gangsta
you know what i'm saying so
even that side was hard
because then you go into the game with
gangsters sometimes you know what i'm
saying and then it was just like
how do you focus on basketball we had
one of our guy kenny ito he called it
they called him 30 sometimes 40 because
that's what he would do he get 30
sometimes 40. he's a great nickname
unbelievable 30 something 30 sometimes
40 is my nickname i love that he started
out 30 sometimes 40 but he got older it
was 30 something okay okay
but he um was playing with rod
strickland at oakland or oak hill yeah
he got shot in the groin he had
scholarships
you know what i mean so many what ifs
right yeah it was crazy like he was dope
you know i mean then mike chatfield was
dope
you know he he got shot up
just ebola you know what i mean and so
it was just like those those case
studies man just like how do you
navigate aways from this
and you were able to do it man yeah yeah
for sure man i was able to you know just
stay i was able to stay away from that
but then also stay in the neighborhood
yeah you know what i mean like because
for me it it felt like
i knew i was going pro
and i know that i know the history of
queens was such a rich history
so for me it was just like how do i like
inspire
and
be cool
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying
and and
not and not desert your roots and not
you know dessert not not really pick
size even though i grew up on the block
right right right here i had my own
crew of friends who might even have beef
or other people but like how do we see
beyond that but still
you know
rep rap you know still represent your
people where you from and your little
clique but at the same time like how do
you move past
you know potential death potential beef
but we still there's still things
happening right now that's some crazy
[ __ ] man yeah that's crazy um
after the bulls obviously got traded to
the pacers um
the pacers run was probably one of the
one of the biggest what-ifs in nba
history
because i do feel like
you guys at a certain point in time had
the best team in the league yeah for
sure top to bottom it just seemed
extremely like
you know dest like like like i'm a sons
fan so one of my what ifs is the year
that uh
steve knows steve nash broke his nose
and mario and borsty i jumped off the
bench yeah that was that was that was
that was a rough year for us but i think
in terms of the pacers like i felt like
everything had kind of lined up for you
guys to kind of have like a like a run
as a unit and i did watch the uh the
netflix documentary which obviously made
on this doc is amazing um it was an
incredible documentary a lot of insight
on that team and and just you too um
but uh
outside of the the championships with
the lakers right what was in your turn
in your what was the best team you ever
were a part of let's just exclude kobe
and the lakers because obviously i mean
you got you got hardware for those the
best team i've ever played on
they're probably
kobe's just incredible but i think the
team will yeah
that y'all were y'all mean
like that wasn't he he i just never seen
nothing like like that guy is different
playing with him was so easy to win
and this is like yeah
yeah yeah people forget like yumming had
a very short run but when he was
yao ming that [ __ ] was i've
never played anyone is dominant so was
t-mac on that team as well t-mac was on
that team that's another big what if
right shane battier shane batty 18 was
kimbe mutombo
was um skip to milo on the right for
austin was on that team
rayford was nice an nba point guard he
was sick
i never knew that it would translate
but it translated he was like one of the
first street guys who i would watch on
n1 mixtapes who actually like
did real [ __ ] in the league he was a but
he was a real street dude right right
right right right for
you and rayford on the same team had to
be great the stories you guys are
probably sharing we we we um yeah i mean
but when i got to houston
it was more about business like rayford
is a bit he's about his business when it
comes to basketball like i didn't know
that about him
so we didn't get a chance to chat much
right i'm going to practice i'm going to
the airport i'm going to hotel i'm going
out sometimes but for the most part i'm
just doing that so you don't get a
chance to share as many stories as i
would have liked to share with rafa but
i mean i grew up playing with him i mean
watching him mm-hmm um idolized them and
then to play on his team was incredible
and then yao ming so just talk about yao
ming you were saying a little bit
earlier like
what was it like having yao ming
as a teammate the guy made the all-star
team every year
you know every year he played he got
voted in but like
he was an incredible player sometimes i
think we forget how good yao ming was
and how good the tmac yao ming one two
punch
with all those role players around him
was oh yeah yeah yeah but what was what
was yaming like as a teammate
great teammate um
[Music]
you know all the teammates is different
but yeah i was he was unique because he
was such a star
and i thought i was going to see
something different like maybe yeah i
have the big boy rolls royce you know
what i mean like
maybe security and all this other stuff
and maybe don't practice
total opposite humble
coach uh rick adaman would have to tell
him stop running because he would do
these running drills after practice
and y'all would do every drill y'all
didn't set out no drills but that's not
typical
you could ask anybody right now on teams
when it's time to do suicides people
that are smaller than y'all
y'all ran every single suicide
but he didn't have to when he should not
have been running because he might have
had a longer career
and we needed him we need his energy but
yeah i was like nah if the if the bench
player is going to do what i'm going to
do that's your me
that's crazy yeah how special was tmac
tmac was special when i got with him he
was hurt he was he
he had already been kind of like down
his back in his knee was really bad yeah
yeah was he was he hard to defend when
you had to defend him on the other side
really hard man i had some lucky days i
think against t-mac
um
[Music]
you know i had some lucky days against
t-mac but when t-mac was on
it was really difficult i mean he was
like a little smaller than durant maybe
three inches smaller than durant but two
inches taller than me
you know what i'm saying and smooth got
left hand right here left feet right
face three ball could drive
can pass
you know i'm saying tmac if he didn't
get hurt
you know i felt like he would have had a
really good career she and i'm you know
i feel like he would have had a karelia
kobe you know if he didn't get hurt
earlier for sure he got hurt in 2009. he
got hurt super early yeah yeah he was a
beast um maybe 2070 he's probably hurt
obviously we always think of you as one
of the best on ball defenders of all
time um you are
you know a legendary defender of the
basketball you were the guy who
whoever the best player was on the other
team you would take them um who was the
hardest player you had to defend hey
lebron
early lebron james well actually i think
jordan was the toughest man so jordan
the reason i was talking about wizards
jordan [ __ ] yeah the first year was his
jordan not um not his last year yeah no
because when he came back mid-season on
the wizards he still had it yeah he had
like a 50-point game he was there for
the whole season
i thought he came back mid season in the
first two and a half seasons with the
wizards so the first year was miss
season next year right after the next
year was the full season and then that
last year was one thing he's got really
average like he was he was he was not
joining but that first year came back he
averaging 25. no i remember that people
be forgetting and that team almost i
remember they had like a tear i mean it
was like him and rip hamilton and like
jaleel white and it was if i was a rough
team i used to play with him on 2k all
the time yeah
i mean but then jordan is not running
like he used to be so easy
even then jordan was tough to defend i
mean the thing about jordan was you knew
what he was going to do you knew what he
was going to do and he's going he's
going to get you all you're going to
pull up he on go left pull up go feed
right and you knew it was coming
we're like lebron when i first started
guarding lebron like lebron i didn't
really know what he was going to do and
he was quite successful but it was still
like you know it wasn't as predictable
which made it a little harder but jordan
i knew exactly what he gonna do
and then kobe was pretty difficult i
mean those guys
you know those guys
but if i had to give it to one i would
probably say jordan
um and your and you and maybe ty with
lebron and kobe lebron and cup i mean
you because you were you were you with
the bulls when you had to defend jordan
with the bulls and one time indiana oh
wow
that's crazy yeah now i got to defend
this guy the whole city's [ __ ] with
him
you uh you've had some like legendary
like uh rivalries throughout your career
who would you say was your biggest rival
on the court which player where you guys
every time you guys freaking got on the
court it was it was something it was
some pushing some shoving well it's
crazy like i haven't i never had a
chance to like let my rivals um mature
because
when i was in indiana the the celtic
rival was becoming something because
they swept us one year then we beat them
and we slept on
so i beat paul more than you being in
the playoffs
but um
paul was one of my rivals because it was
a constant it was very consistent
throughout my career playing against
paul but then with kobe in my prime i
got suspended
so i didn't see kobe that year and then
the next year i got suspended again
people forget i got to spend two years
in a row
for two for three months so then but
then i went to sacramento then i was
then i saw kobe but i didn't see paul
anymore and then the the ben wallace
uh rival was great that was more that
was just like a
hard work
yeah yeah because both you guys were
hard-nosed
players yeah so that was a that was
probably my
for me it was my biggest rival because
how hard he worked and i didn't really
like anybody working harder than me and
he was getting defensive player of the
year you know what i mean and he got the
rings
and he got the rings you know what i
mean so and he's a hall of famer so for
me that was like somebody that i you
guys will always be uh tied together
because of uh because what happened to
the brawl yeah and and and also because
of that era
he got defensive played here 2002
2003 i led the league in flagrant fouls
um any and and uh and technical files so
the media wasn't messing with me but i
finished two
and
i think i finished second in mvp in
defense played a year but he got it
again
then i got it the next year
then the next year i was going i i was
going but nobody can tell i got
suspended between you and rasheed
wallace who who had more technical
thousands in their careers for sure
because that was like i feel like i
probably had more flagrance
yeah so yeah he had more technicals i
don't think he has more flagrance than
me do you think you could have played in
today's nba because i feel like today's
nba is a little bit softer flagrant
fouls you get i feel like i think i
could i think i think you know every
player
every era has a player that's like a
wild card you know what i mean
i don't know who it is this error you
think it's pat beverly i mean pat
beverly is a very um
he's an aggressive player like i don't
think he's a dirt he he did some dirty
[ __ ] chris paul last year westbrook
he nailed chris paul in the backlash i
mean he's an aggressive player yeah i
don't think he's as aggressive as i was
because i think he's more like control
and discipline do you think you were a
dirty player
um uh at a certain point in time maybe
well i was very physical it would seem
dirty but i never i would play with like
i would use my files so
if we got six fouls i knew how to play
with five files
so every game i'm using my files
depending on um the bonus situation
right right right every game i'm using
my files
um every game i'm not gonna let you post
up so
and i'll do anything you know and it's
up to the refs to call it
um i i think i was
more than dirty i was just really strong
so it was like there was really nothing
people could do
who uh the exception of a few people
who
i remember as a kid i always used to
think like there was a couple of players
in the nba who i would not want to fight
in real life you were one of them but
ben wallace was one of them
in your opinion during your career which
uh which basketball player had in your
opinion had some hands that like not a
lot of people know about well it's some
people that real talent like uh well
shaq
shaq is also a talented fighter also
body slam by charles barkley but that
was like
yeah
but you know shaq is jack is a different
breed like you know like a shout out to
uh uh
williams just beat up frank gore in a
boxing match
i did not see that coming
yeah i thought frank gore was going to
do it for sure i think the greatest
fighter is um
the kid johnson from the heat yes
because he's actual uh
james johnson right james johnson yeah
he's uh got like black belts he's a real
fighter yeah i think he's been just
getting signed his career has been going
on as long as it has because they're
like we just need to throw someone in
to eat up those fouls yeah but he's a
good player actually yeah no he's had a
great career um talk about your lakers
run man you know the one thing that i
thought was dope about the documentary
that came out um
obviously you have your documentary that
came out about your life but the netflix
documentary got a lot of publicity last
year
was when you got the ring
you kind of um trying to make peace with
the indiana situation
when you got interviewed i think it was
it was post-game after the finals had
ended right
um
do you feel like your lakers run was
kind of like
redemption for you as a player and just
kind of redemption for you as a career
for sure lakers gave me a big
opportunity you know i got a call from
my agent at about 1201
on the deadline i mean well actually
when start of the
or the a free agency
said the latest one wanted to pick me
wanted to sign me
next morning i had
breakfast with or lunch with dr bus
and we just talked a little bit about it
can you say he knew how my career was he
thought that i was gonna
you know become a better more stable
player and
and um that helped him win
and it happened and it rejuvenated my
career because the reason i did i always
thought i'd be a champion i play i won
everywhere high school new york city
27-0
aau ball 67-1 wow you know what i mean
like i went everywhere so in the nba was
like my plan was to win
but
because i wasn't ready for it at the
time
you know i was plus you could drink it
you also get drafted into weird
situations like you got drafted into a
bulls team that wasn't ready to win they
were actively rebuilding like you were
active
how'd you maybe got drafted to like i
don't know san antonio or detroit or
something yeah it would have been
different it would have been out yeah it
would have been loaded we always think
like what would happen if mello would
have went to the pistons instead of uh
daario you know yeah it would have been
big
but you know but that that wasn't the
real issue the issue was like me i
personally
led
you know myself to not winning more
games playing more from being suspended
and getting ejected you know i always
tell people when you get ejected that's
one less point
that you're gonna have it's one less
rebound and when you total all the
numbers up at the end of your career
you know you that you're gonna you're
gonna be where you're at so that's why i
always tell people if you could play a
game play the game
you know um like even with ben simmons
he missed so much games that's like
2 000 points right you know what i'm
saying yeah at the end of his career
we're gonna think think about that you
think about kawhi kawai's career totals
are very low compared to who he's
compared to
because of the rings he has
but if you look at his career totals
compared to like
his counterparts they're a lot lower
because he's missed so much time for
injuries i mean but yeah but his unique
as injuries
but no but ben ben should you know i
mean obviously was more just you know it
was a mental injury he was i mean you've
been through like your your issues with
with just mental health which i think
you were kind of one of the first
players that kind of embraced like
uh facing that uh
when you saw the ben simmons thing
playing out recently obviously he just
got traded to the nets it looks like
he's going to be playing soon um did you
kind of
have any sort of like did you kind of
relate to what he could be going through
or did you like how did you kind of feel
about the ben simmons
thing well he's not the first player to
go through something
since i retired or even as since i've
been thinking about
like what players go through
that's one of the reasons i started to
come out but
um that situation was really unique
because like i wanted him to play
for sure i personally wanted to see him
play
um
[Music]
so
but then i also understand i wanted to
retire when i was 23.
so i kind of understand a little bit
on not wanting to play or something
getting in the way
like nothing should ever get in the way
of you playing i think it's a way to hit
like if you want to get traded i think
it's a way to handle it
you know um because i handle it the
wrong way so i'm thinking about it you
you took those those wounds for him kind
of like yo i i like you like you said
you you you you handled at certain point
in times in your career you handled
things the wrong way yeah there's a way
to handle [ __ ] right yeah so i think i
think for every circumstance in the nba
is a way to handle it like for example
if you don't want to be on the team
you can
talk to your agent talk to the owner or
general manager and be like listen
i don't want to be here
um i don't want to make a big deal out
of it
so i'm a play but let's really
moved me but what then what happens is
what if the fans start loving you right
what are you playing well and the fans
start loving you right and then now the
general manager gonna look crazy by
trading right right cause y'all don't
have no issues but how do you really
handle it or maybe you can say hey i
don't want to be here
but still play the game still be a
professional i guess right i mean a
teammate
i couldn't tell someone to be
professional because i wasn't
professional so i don't like to really
say things that i wasn't
yeah you had some pretty unprofessional
moments you know what i'm saying yeah
you know i don't i don't know like to
call nobody like be professional
but i could say be professional but i i
wouldn't want to say like
um you know you're not professional just
leave it there i would like to like
explain why i think like you should be
more professional or why i would benefit
you you know what i'm saying versus like
criticizing yeah you've been through it
yeah i've done it yeah yeah um did you
ever request formally a trade while you
were in the league um i didn't actively
try to get up out of somewhere like
unprofessional unprofessionally yeah
was that in indiana um
in chicago i pretty much
forced that one
indiana
i was very unprofessional by coming out
in the media and saying i want to be
traded
sacramento no
just those two teams did you win because
you actually the knicks was um linux
also the knicks i forgot you played for
the next i played the next end of my
career i didn't request the trade but i
was like kind of upset
wait so you left the pacers and before
you went to the lakers you're on the
kings for a run for like almost four
years i think i don't even remember
those fours yeah
that was some really big years for me it
was sacramento because that was like
after the weber pages after that
who was even on that team i can't even
remember the kings after chris webber so
when i when i got there they was in
kings was like in 12th place some
something like that
i get there oh you did have a crazy run
on the camera
diverse player but we had brad miller
who was very fast brad millard number 40
mike bibby mike bibby was still hanging
around brad miller brad miller was a
double double brad miller was incredible
just a strong white guy with a headband
yo brad had no abs no chest muscles no
arm muscles but he can run
and
i think he made one all-star game he did
he made one hell of a player man yeah
brad miller
but very very cerebral
like
more smart i remember skills i remember
he was on the bulls and the kings right
he was on the bus right yeah i played
with him i played with brad with the
bulls indiana
and inside that's so crazy
i follow brad everywhere um
you know obviously we think about your
time with kobe um
you've talked about extensively about
your relationship with kobe
did you feel like your
time around kobe made you a better
person
i think it made me um
i'm not gonna say a better person
i think my time around kobe
it made me more centered and it may be
better but it just made me more centered
because he was focusing on the
championship
and he was so stable mentally
you know whereas i wasn't um
when you talk about sports or sports
therapy right focusing on the game right
he was so stable
where it made me do things aren't being
a little uncomfortable
focus
and focus from
training camp to championship
and go through the ups and downs
adversity like how do you get through
adversity so from a sports perspective
he made me a a really centered player
um
which i you know which i really
appreciate
what was uh
like advice wise or just talk wise can
you remember like one of the better
talks you had with kobe was it maybe
after a game did he did he have to ever
have to pull you off to the side and say
hey look you're doing this we got to do
this or like yeah man i mean we spent a
lot of time together of course we were
on the court i've started together so
but for the most part i mean
yeah i think um we had a few talks
but i was pretty cerebral you know you
give me the offense
the strategy on defense
there's nothing really much to say to me
you know do you think there was any
misconceptions we think about kobe
because we always hear he was a tough
teammate
he was tough he was tough but you know
when you out work someone you know i
didn't really experience that derek
fisher probably didn't experience that
but some new players
who don't understand that the work
that it takes
i mean he gonna let you have it
like you gotta really step up your work
ethic you know um your confidence you're
not going to be getting a lot of touches
so
when you get the ball you need to be
fully locked in who do you think um on
those lakers teams that you were on
because because there were some young
players like andrew bynum was young and
and uh
was that i'm trying to think who else
was was uh
what was the three point sasha sasha
sasha was a was a young just yeah we had
a young team man a young there was a lot
of young players on that roster like
who was kobe the hardest on
um
i feel like him and sasha probably had
most of the going back and forth to join
because
but but i think
when i got there sasha became a champion
a championship type of player but i
could imagine when i wasn't
when i wasn't in the beginning i think
sasha might have been like
you know
didn't understand the work ethic and you
got to really buy in
you gotta buy in you guys are gonna work
yeah you can't bring anything you
however you are
it ain't anything like that here and i
think um but when i got there
that team was full of uh
you know full of uh hard-nosed gangsters
right right you know so
it was easy hey we got to stop the
interview real quick man shout out to
our sponsors at my bookie now if you're
into sports like me you like to win
money
what are we doing go to my bookie right
now man let's get in on some of this
action
my bookie go sign up get the double
deposit bonus that's what this means
when you sign up in my bookie right now
all right whatever money you would
deposit they're gonna match it they're
gonna double it for you up to a thousand
dollars but you gotta use the key word
the promo code
bootleg that's right use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up at mybookie
they're gonna double your deposit listen
march madness is coming up
my favorite time of the year to gamble
is march madness it is so much fun you
don't got to know a [ __ ] thing about
college basketball it is just [ __ ]
turnt up i love to go to
listen march madness that's really all
you need to know get your account before
then thank me later also nba action is
finally back throw down some futures who
do you think is going to win the mvp
joel embiid jokic devin booker a little
dark horse you know i'm saying shout out
to the suns uh you got to go to my
bookie though sign up get down right now
all right get double your money double
your deposit you put in a thousand
they're gonna match that give you a
whole another thousand to gamble with
mybookie.ag
use the promo code bootleg double your
deposit right now meta you were just
talking about how you're you you got a
game tonight you're still running you're
still you're still active what is like
20 22 what are you doing how are you
spending your your post nba years yeah
man so we got our test management group
which is my management company that i've
been working on for quite some time
so that's kind of keeping me really busy
so we have a sports component which you
mentioned in sports so we have like a
tech company that
uh help basketball players
get exposure
sign up to the app we help find and
facilitate games and try to get you more
exposure women and men so that's been
something that's been taken up my time a
lot is called x-versus exports
then we also have a business management
um company where we do like taxes
reconciliations and different things i
was the busy time of the year for that i
just got married yeah yeah yeah for sure
but we got like
we got like top boxes that signed to us
so you pretty much kind of help with
like managing money let me ask you i
invested in the company oh okay so i'm
not i'm not day-to-day with that company
i just invested in it but then we signed
anthony mongia
yeah canelo is a client of ours canelo
we had uh charlie black um larry sanders
for a little bit um corey joseph i think
we still have him right now
some real estate some billionaire real
estate guys so that company is doing
well you know i'm really excited about
that one you're gonna have a couple
others you've obviously been a
millionaire for a long time what is uh a
lesson about money that you've learned
that you would like to try to you know
kind of spread because a lot of people
don't understand
just financial literacy in general
especially especially when you get that
much money you know what i'm saying
what's something that you had to kind of
learn the hardware or some game you
could give it's just about financial
sure for sure man
every i think um
like one would say find people you can
trust but then you even look at some of
the instances the incidents that's
happening with some pros where
like these uh some people took
buckets of money
you know so i was like how do you find
somebody you trust you're working with
the smartest people in suits right so
but find somebody you trust but also do
your own diligence if you can i mean if
you can pay some of your own bills do it
just start you know if you say you're a
first round pick or like a new artist
you know okay maybe you know what you're
going to make 100 million 200 300 400
500 million because this is happening
but i think in the beginning stages you
should be doing a lot of it on your own
you should know something about your
taxes know something about bill pay you
know you should know something about
diversifying your portfolio
you know sometimes we have so much cash
sitting in the bank it's like we're not
going to spend all this cash today or
you will spend it but certainly on the
wrong things right but you can actually
take a chunk of that and put it to work
you're not going to spend you know 100
million yeah go buy a apartment building
or
do you know i feel like a lot of young
nba players there's a lot of people who
kind of
you know financially
are predatory towards some of these
young athletes and artists like when it
comes to
did you ever have anyone try to get in
your pockets or try to mismanage your
situation
i had a good people man i think i had
good people around me um i'm very
independent
so for me
um i always wanted to do my own thing
stop my own management company i wanted
my own shoes now you know what i mean so
but you know i think um you know for the
most part
you know i think it's a huge opportunity
i mean these athletes are corporations
it's like new corporations within a day
i mean a great return on our you know
company or you're making two million
dollars a year you're like oh i made two
million this year right that's great
these guys is making 50 million 10 mil
20 mil
like that's a corporation
some real [ __ ] man that is that is
literally a corporation
yeah in a year think about the new yeah
there's someone james harden's about to
opt in to 47 million dollars i'm like
jesus christ
what was your biggest year like that you
had in the nba as far as just
the most i've made was 40. i made 40
twice wow but you know
my skill level would request more but
because i was getting so much trouble
every time it was time to get more
or max you got 240 40 million dollar
contract yeah wow so i always i always
got the minimum
yeah you i mean yeah but it was i'm
grateful yeah i'm grateful hell yeah
like when i when i got drafted i i work
in a circuit city like i i shout out to
circuit city i never got i got i applied
for a job at circuit city when i got
drafted you know what i'm saying so i
was never like
needed a lot okay i've never had like a
bentley i've never had a rose you know
what i'm saying um
but so for me i was i was fortunate
enough to be like that type of person
but i also wish like i would have never
made those mistakes because i it was
times where teams say we gonna match you
out
you know but
then you get in trouble i was going to
say do you ever feel like you were more
focused on music and other like was
music ever did you ever make being an
artist a priority over being an nba
player sure when you're in the studio i
got 500 songs
that's a lie
you know what i'm saying
wow
and then like i would say
300 of them or maybe 204
not finished
so but i got 100 of them
that i was in the studio for 16 hours
because you know it takes like yeah
about 14 16 hours of because you are
extremely active as far as just putting
out music
i put out three albums my last season my
career now you put out a lot nobody know
about it i
what's funny is like um
we always think of like
nba players who have tried to do the
label thing like kd for a while had an
artist he was working with melo cassidy
was signed to carmelo anthony for a
little bit
stoddameyer had a label i love music
it's sports hip-hop and
basketball are so synonymous with each
other but i do feel like as an artist
you probably had one of the more like
active runs like i was very active some
people were i'm surpr like some people
kind of discredit that but i was active
for a long time but nobody worked and
you were putting out music with like a
lot of like legends yeah i was probably
a lot of people but one of the things i
wish there was a couple things i wish i
did with music
like when i retired i was going to do
one of four things
full-time music
and i actually thought about this
full-time music i studied for my series
seven
so i was studying for series seven um
management what i'm doing now or
or all the marketing
and then as i was going through it the
pros and cons of music was being up late
being in the because i was going to do
it i wouldn't give 110 percent yeah so i
chose to go back to ucla and went back
to school i went back to concordia
irvine but when i was putting on music
[ __ ] i was i mean i got a champion sold
150 000 that's crazy you know that was
my most successful record
and um i mean i was engineering most
artists nowadays can't sell 150 000
units just just to be honest i mean it's
a different different time
different circumstances but 150 000
units is a big win for a lot of artists
i appreciate that one i wish i i think i
should have
i would have been if i would have writer
now i look back at it
i would i wouldn't i would have wished i
would have a writer
a
because i was doing records with
everybody
i mean i was in position to win yeah but
i don't think i
um the operational side of musical and
it's a hard mountain to get over to be
taken serious
when people think of you as that
all-time great basketball player that's
true but being from queensbridge and my
whole story no you had a crazy story you
had the street cred you had all that but
i just mean in terms of like it's hard
for people to like look at it at someone
i think damien uh has done a good job he
does a good job he's doing a good job uh
obviously back in the day shaq had some
plasma records obviously um shaq for a
while jack damien iman i like i like his
album as though iman came in freestyle
then [ __ ] caught a body you know he's
incredible i'm not a freestyler i'm more
like emotional you know right so i like
when i get into the booth i'm just
thinking about something that happened
and then you're trying to write it down
and that's it it's more like when i'm on
stage i'm like fully in um
on stage i think like you know i'm fully
in cheat up mode on stage like i'm ready
yeah hey what's crazy is um we always
think about the finals that we never got
to see and that is lebron versus kobe we
never got to see that uh that was crazy
it's it's wild to think that that never
happened
um being on those teams at that time
how like actually real was like the kobe
lebron
rivalry in terms of just like you know
we
their sports center people talk on like
skip bayless these guys were talking at
the time like what was that something
that you think kobe actually kind of was
like okay
i'm still that [ __ ] even though
everyone's trying to say that yeah we
went to the finals yeah just in general
just like oh yeah he's
kobe wanted that matchup for sure i'm
sure lebron wanted that matchup too
i mean we we forget how tough lebron is
but i think kobe for sure wanted that
matchup and he would talk about it
um but the neighbors that they was
actually the number one seed that year
but then they lost to the magic right
they lost to the magic it was the number
one seed so when we got to the finals we
had home court advantage against boston
you know what i mean so
that they would have had home court
advantage on us if that finals would
have happened which would have been like
not to our favor but you said kobe
wanted that [ __ ] for sure yeah because
that because legacy you know what i mean
that's a legacy moment yeah everybody
that's like like it would have been
legacy for me too if i you know if we
would play you would have been guarding
him i would have been guarding him if we
win
like those those are moments that you
got to calculate and try to you know
accomplish but
you know it didn't happen so right right
right um was um
you know we i think sometimes we think
back to like the magic team that made
the finals yeah
was kind of one of those teams like
dwight not making the top 75 players to
me was kind of crazy because for like 10
years he was the best center in the
league for sure for sure in in the land
of
you know he was more dominant than a lot
of these players that right now like he
took the magic to the finals
you know and this is a east that had kg
ray allen
uh and paul pierce on the celtics and
the lebron cavaliers he did exactly what
lebron did yeah um for the most part
yeah from playing a different way yeah
playing a different way very dominant
obviously the celtics series are
legendary
um
what was your uh favorite finals to play
in i only played in one you only played
in one and a lot of people did a lot of
people think i played them more i
thought you played it more i know i was
that type of player you would think you
would have thought out of it in the
finals more everybody said how many
fights how many races i thought you were
two years with the lakers in the finals
no no i just played one time
i got it and one got lucky and i'm
grateful 22 that was 2010 right 2010.
wow
that's 17
yo um
how tough were the suns in 2010
because again they're pretty tough they
were small
they were a small team besides robin
robin lopez it was kind of they were
very very small but they could shoot
yeah yeah that was they i mean they
could just shoot that rock
and then when you got steve nash
steve that we had to go up against that
yes chris paul and steve nash
was that chris paul on the hornets
hornets yeah hornet cp but probably
david west man that was tough david was
a tough guy we talked about guys who
could fight david west one of those guys
oh yeah
david west is a tough dude yeah he's a
tough guy for sure who reminds you of
yourself the most right now in the
league um
in my prime
i was i mean my prime kawhi
you know um
playing at my best
um
[Music]
probably kawhi because he was he said he
he lock you up
and he um to play offense
you know what i'm saying and also he's
like he's not gonna always get 40 and 40
and 40. right he gonna get 28 34
27 but be the best player on the floor
100 you know what i'm saying which is
like
i could i could relate i never had 40 in
the nba
you know but i was the go-to guy
multiple teams yeah you were yeah but i
was spending so much time on defense so
kawhi is somebody who i really like
do you think um
you know in in the the league has
changed so much with three-point
shooting obviously the warriors kind of
revolutionized the way kids are grow up
watching basketball
um
do you think defense has kind of gotten
lost in
in the in the uh
in the kind of you know when we were
kids when i was watching you or watching
you know the era before you when you
were watching basketball defense was a
very important part of the game yeah
nowadays it feels like it's so secondary
that like the league like we'll see some
of these scores especially this year the
scores are crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah
like putting up 130 is nothing now where
like back in the day if someone put up
130 you'd be like what the [ __ ] well
they took the hands off right i can't
touch as much
um so you don't really have a reason to
love defense
you know what i'm saying right now
like when i was growing up it was a
reason why i was doing my defensive
slides in the summertime while i was in
bay while i was a pro because i had to
stop someone and it was aggressive
and
you know our last game against detroit
it was a 70
73 to 69. crazy to go to the finals
that's so crazy you know that's a
college score
to go to the finals that is so crazy
most of the games i played in in the
playoffs
were all low scores
mostly that's real the the lakers would
be the boston 83 83.79 wow you can't
even think about that um what do you
think is the biggest misconception about
about you
well i mean i don't really know man it's
a lot but i just try to move on because
eric
i mean we're human you know i mean so
a misconception to me is like an opinion
from somebody else have and it's fine
you know but
um
[Music]
it's definitely i mean i definitely
a product of my environment and i love
my environment so
i'm not gonna say there's any
misconceptions this really you know it
is what it is hey we got to stop the
podcast man real quick appreciate y'all
for watching uh really mean mean it
subscribe like leave a comment even if
you're one of those [ __ ] who leaves
a comment yo why you always interrupting
the guest because it's my [ __ ]
podcast i don't know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssoxofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
who who's your goat who do you think is
the greatest of all time bill russell
bill russell for sure over kobe over
lebron over
bill's got 11 championships and and bill
gain would have translated to today
because he was the most athletic big
yeah if you gotta if you get if you put
bill russell in today's game
he dominate he he he can block shots
he's gonna rebound everything
he he fasted in the guards
how about this lebron or jordan
[Music]
um
that's a tough one well
um
well i'm guarded both
but this is the thing
jordan never lost in the finals lebron
has
lebron's been to 10 of them though right
so but lebron's been attended
um
jordan skipped out on two
now one would argue that houston would
have won all right cool
when jordan won his last one he left
so that was a
we're talking nine rings
we talking nine when he came back
averaging 25 he was clearly able to
still play
we talking the same type yeah like if
you would have stayed they would have
beat this they would have beat the spurs
because that was the uh i think that was
the blackout yeah yeah that was the the
lockout you know what i'm saying so it's
just like for me it's just like
but now you talk about lebron lebron did
everything it takes to be the best
because he stayed healthy
he's still playing
yeah i think it's 19 years he's been in
the league now 19 years and the stuff
he's doing he's having statistically
maybe his best year statistically he's
not moving a lot right but he's still
playing the playing high level it's
crazy his offense is sick it's insane um
you know but with that being said you
gotta pick one
that's really hard because i mean this
guy lebron he's the number one scorer in
history right now
so you're picking lebron it's hard
you gotta pick pick one
i mean you have to go to lebron
the reason this is why
he's played 19 years his stats is
incredible
now i can i can i can i can make a point
for jordan
but if i might just look at the numbers
i got i think lebron is probably the top
five passer of all time i feel like you
just get a lot more with lebron if
you're like if you let's say you were
drafting right you're like i want lebron
or i want you you know you're going to
get us so much more with lebron
i mean
they diff
they're different they are different you
know what i like to think of is like
when lebron went to the finals in 07
against the spurs with kind of like a
very weak team eric snow was the
starting point guard um
they had a big z as the center
jordan really had to get pippin to get
over the
the pistons hump you gotta get a lot of
people to get over the pistons huh yeah
and i feel like before that he you know
well lebron had to go see wade
no for sure but he made it to the finals
though
i mean obviously they got swept by the
spurs the white majors are the finals no
you're right
a lot of people made it to the finals no
you're right you're right i mean yeah
but dwight didn't make it 10 times
so right so
but jordan jordan you know
i mean and then lebron was in cleveland
so that's not fair jordan was in chicago
nobody wanted to play there carl's
carlos boozer [ __ ] lebron over and
went to the jazz he had a lot i'm a big
lebron guy it was hard for lebron i mean
i love lebron and their big offseason
move was getting anton james i almost
went to the cavs i told people to start
i almost went to the cavs what year
did when yeah i went to the lakers so
you almost went and joined lebron yeah i
was talking lebron a little bit about
going to the cavs but did lebron call
you to try to recruit you smoke like
maybe two minutes three minutes what was
his pitch to you to come to cleveland
just real quick just real quick like you
know we're here
he called it he didn't need a pitch even
on five years older than him but at that
point in time in his career
legendary right so you look up to that
so i was like oh wow this is pretty dope
but um i was actually trying to go back
to indiana so when i first i was in
houston so i was trying to go back to
houston because
we just lost the lakers i wanted to
redeem myself
then um when the houston said no
then i called my agent i want to go back
to indiana
then when indiana said no
then um
i tried to get to detroit
which would have been great that would
have been so crazy yeah i was trying to
go to pistons
um and then jojo dumas was the general
manager he's like nah
i almost went to the knicks
as if isaiah i mean isaiah got in a
little issue
the nickname was off the table so that's
i was probably going to be a nick
at 29 years old which i was like
that would have been incredible right
and then um
when uh when king james uh reached out
then and they're not gonna and then um
the lakers also reached out so it was
between cleveland and l.a um
when it when it boils down to it
yeah you you might have been the
difference maker in 2010 for the cavs
i was trying honestly i was trying not
to play with kobe or lebron honestly
r.i.p my brother kobe i was because i
wanted to play against those guys mm-hmm
um but then when but then
when no teams wanted me you got it
lebron the cavs did yeah all lebron did
but i couldn't get any other teams so
when that happened i had to backtrack
like yo
hey i'm playing with one of the stars
man you know and they only offered me
the minimum so i was just like whatever
at this point whatever man
who's the most underrated teammate you
ever had in the nba do you feel like
don't get enough flowers um well yeah
obviously like because the nba market
certain people and people more outgoing
but johnny salmons john salmons was
solid solid players on the kings right
yeah i remember i had him in fantasy
basketball great players john simmons
yeah um
jameson brewer from indiana pacers back
in the days he don't get no credit he
way ahead of his time
um we have jonathan bendy got hurt early
bender was nice on the pacers was nice
um he was was he in the done contest i
feel like he might have been he could
dunk his yeah he was a beast i remember
john was like
yeah he was nice same thing yeah bender
was nice for sure
maylor strong a better shot blocker
but the same exact player yeah jonathan
bender was nice then who also underrated
i think um
[Music]
trent hassell
i know yeah trying to defense not his
offense he can shoot but his defense was
probably
he probably was top
10
from 2000s to now
trent house was probably with top 10
winning defenders that's crazy to think
of a lot of nba players that played
against him they know that
he was incredible would you ever do a
podcast
i mean i i'm off and on with a podcast
you know what i'm saying because i feel
like uh
i feel like either that or just like you
know i think of like guys who get paid
to go speak to people to motivate them
whether it's gary vee or like mike tyson
i feel like there's a lot of money out
there for you to be like a motivational
speaker man to go speak at conferences
and i feel like your story's so crazy
yeah um
it is it's um it is you know i think
it's opportunities but it's
i like i never had a manager or i do now
but my whole
pro career i didn't have like a
entertainment manager
or like an entertainment agent i ain't
even needed that i just
i was just doing my own thing you know i
mean but from that perspective when you
have like those high people in place
they can find opportunities like that
right so now you know we're thinking
about like doing a few things but i'm
still just like
kind of in a little bubble
you know i mean focusing on my my
business and stuff yeah you got so much
other business adventures going on uh
this big trade just happened i want to
just get your opinion uh hard into the
sixers
obviously ben simmons seth curry are now
on the nets uh as well as andre drummond
um who do you think won the trade
oh wow
i think both teams won this is why
because you got people that want to be
there they both kind of got better right
yeah it's a very rare instance where
like both teams kind of won especially
with ben simmons plays
seth curry's he just had the thing he's
27 last night he's incredible yeah yeah
that guy is incredible man he's not as
good as his brother but he is a right
he's a really good player if everyone
might be all-star one year i think so
everybody's healthy who do you like in
the finals like who do you like to win
the championship this year consider
they've helped
if everyone's healthy on every team oh
my goodness the lakers
really
man what's the problem with the lakers
this year because everyone's pointing at
russell westbrook no it's not all
russell
and and
nobody's gonna come out and say oh no
this is the reason why this is the
reason why right russell's not going to
point the finger then lebron it felt
like they were going to try to trade him
at least like it felt like it it's a
unique situation because the guys are
like older
so then a.d goes down a.d wasn't in the
best shape coming in not for sure right
so a.d wasn't so
so when you had that i think
that was um
i think people was like oh man
because the ag that won the title was
different
very much so got a different a.d
so
then lebron gets hurt a little bit
and even a year before that lebron gets
hurt right right right it's just a funky
fit it just feels like uh
remember that ankle injury yeah i
remember i like if you if you're not a
championship how about this if you're
the gm of the lakers
and it's the trade deadline hasn't hit
yet how do you fix the lakers what moves
are you making i think you just get
better man no moves i think i think what
they need to do because the lakers is
not the
eighth worst team in the west of course
not and right now they're like 10. right
now the 10th yeah they're moving down
yeah they're moving the wrong way yeah
yeah but i think like
they just need to get better game by
game move the ball play together and
don't worry about anything else
um you know move your feet on defense
yeah i feel like defensively there's so
many guys that take off possessions
i think i think
the other thing is this they're older
what would be advice if you're russell
westbrook's teammate on the lakers this
year and there's so much outside noise
happening what would be some game you
would try to give them as a veteran just
tell them to play you know i mean as if
i was just play
that's it you know um
you're not he's not perfect nobody is
he's still having triple double nights
so he's doing some things well but then
we're highlighting the turnovers which
is a lot
some of the late game decisions some of
the late game decisions
and as a coach you just watch the film
and say listen
you should not have done this you should
not have done this right so if i was if
i was in that situation but if i was
like just in a situation where i'm just
coming across them
i mean i would just say you know just
have fun and keep playing
you know i'm saying have fun keep
playing and try to win that's it uh last
two questions one
you kind of were active in the beginning
of
what i like to call what sports media
has become
like when you were
active a lot of these guys the skip
baylesses of the world the steven a's
were just getting their feet wet but
you very much were a talking point of a
lot of those guys did you ever have any
real serious issues with any of the uh
espn
uh conversations that were happening in
regards to some of the debate shows
cause some of those guys be saying some
wild [ __ ] nah but the thing is this
when i
i'm
i i just i'm not gonna make this a race
thing i don't like that but what i would
say is this
when i came i'm from new york so being
from new york
craziest media market in the world crazy
media market but you also have a lot of
different faiths and beliefs
you go 125th street harlem right
so
when you're talking about coming into a
different structure you know
corporate
it wasn't always our favorite so i
already went into it knowing like
to expect the worst you know what i'm
saying because i never changed i came
into the league on some hood [ __ ] you
know i came into the league like
queensbridge represented it wasn't like
i want to do commercials right right i
want people to know like i'm from
queensbridge
so just that alone you know i knew i
wasn't going to get
you know a lot of things that i still
wanted to be like the nba player but i
never wanted to forget so i never
listened honestly i didn't listen to a
lot of that stuff did you think that you
were trying to ever like buy up uh any
of of of qb like as far as like any of
the buildings you're on i didn't but
when i came out in 1999 i didn't know
about real estate right you know like
that's fair you know economics or
economy and growth and i didn't really
understand that last thing you're one of
the greatest defenders of all time
put together your top your starting five
of defenders
just the top best like if you had to put
together five guys on a team to just
best defenders ever who's who who's
making the team man dennis rodman
that's not russell okay
um dennis rodman
and his prime
incredible
to defend all five positions all five
including shaquille o'neal oh my
goodness he's incredible
um bill russell
um
i would say wilt but i think will
might take off possessions on defense i
could see that he was he was too busy
[ __ ] the night before he was out
[ __ ]
i i feel like he's so talented
where he probably wouldn't just take up
possession so i'll go with
um
actually i'm taking it back i'm gonna go
because he's so tough
he's tough wilt russell rodman robbie at
the fourth um robin playing three
defensive okay
he's quick
i'll go with me
and then i'll go with uh
i go with jordan jordan and that and and
now and i'm leaving gary payton off
which is not what i would like to do
um
but
if i use that group i think we lock up
like really amazingly
where do you put tony allen in that
discussion because a lot of people kind
of think i feel like tony allen was such
a specialist in terms of just defense
like tony he's bringing a lot more to
the table like on offense but
defensively he was nice see
tony me and tony are in the same era and
we are using a championship together
also
see but with tony like they all
the the reason like
i don't mention tony a lot
is it's actually a couple reasons one
they was talking about me a lot
but then in tony's world they talking
about tony yeah right then brute butt
when you talk about defensive player
when he was in
bruce bowen bruce bowen i forgot about
bruce i'm saying bruce bowen myself and
right and that's right when tony came
into the league
you know but like bruce bond and trent
hassler and obviously ben wallace and
nowadays we have mikhail bridges on the
suns
he's a good defender oh he's amazing
really oh yeah he's gonna be first team
at all defense this year wow i didn't
know that yeah i know he is ben simmons
is an amazing defender ben simmons is
pretty good he's he's he's that guy for
sure well listen tony man i think tony
like
people respect him as a defender for
sure a lot of people i don't think i
watched enough to see how good of a
defender
and i played against him sometimes so i
i'm 2 260. so anybody guarding me if you
it doesn't really feel like defense who
was the toughest guy
that you went up against on offense that
had to defend you like who you who just
would lock you up or you were just like
this yeah i did have this is a headache
today some people like matt harpering
was kind of tough because he was
physical
and i wasn't i wanted we were just
banging so i kind of enjoy
that was a tough one on defense so
guardian
mad a tough one
um
[Music]
there was a couple guys out there
that was tough but i was you know 260 is
not much you could do
there's not much i don't care how good a
defender i'll just put you in the block
there it is
there it is well listen man uh anything
else you want to promote before you get
up out of here nah i'm at this i'm happy
to be on your show man i appreciate you
coming by man it's an honor bro i'm
pretty thankful
for sure qb's finest in here meta world
peace the legend um yo for people who
haven't gone and watched the documentary
to you about your life it is a great
watch it's uh is it a showtime
documentary yeah we got the showtime doc
on my life called quiet storm after marv
d of course then we got the madison
palace on netflix which is jermaine
o'neill produced that one
um it's called untold how's you and
jermaine's uh relationship these things
that's cool man i was really it's better
than i'm happy where is that do you feel
like that documentary was kind of a
healing thing for everybody because it
felt that way i was happy with it it
felt like it was like a healing moment i
didn't like it initially because i was
thinking about more the business side i
wasn't thinking about the healing i was
thinking about economics but when i saw
it i was like wow this is
you know this outweighs the economics
in terms of what it did for us
you know what it did for the guys that
was involved
i think it told that the story of that
team and just like
i think it did justice in terms of just
like
i don't think you guys get enough credit
for what how good that team was how good
you were at that time and i feel like
coming away from that documentary
it kind of we we don't that was so long
ago that people don't
remember how unfair of a shake you got
in terms of this
it was very and it did feel very racial
it did feel very like
it felt kind of like i didn't feel it i
didn't feel the racist the the racial
side because i always approach things as
like i don't give a [ __ ] life yeah i i
was already on offense anyway but
and then i was in the middle of it
mm-hmm so i wasn't really focusing on
like a lot of things that were going
around it but then i looked at it i'm
like
i some of these comments i was like oh
yeah i was [ __ ] like crazy so i'm
crazy
i was like wow and you were just these
guys still on tv and they still are on
tv
they still are but listen man i
appreciate you pulling up go watch all
that [ __ ] and go support this guy
whatever you got going on i got you man